un engagement que des allures de déjà-vu
de la part des pays les plus riches du
monde réunis à Sapporo au Japon en
pleine crise climatique les pays du G7
veulent accélérer leur sortie des
énergies fossiles dans tous les secteurs
un objectif louable mais pour lequel les
pays ne se sont fixés au que nouvelle
échéance il n'y a pas de date à cet
engagement il n'y a pas non plus
d'engagement à ne plus approuver ou
financer de nouveaux projets pétroliers
gaziers donc c'est une demi avancée une
demi avancée que regrette également la
porte-parole d'équitters qui déplore le
manque d'ambition du Canada durant ce
sommet le Canada a des engagements et
c'est important qu'il les porte à
l'international le Canada aurait dû
jouer un rôle beaucoup plus proactif à
ces niveaux là l'environnementalis ne
peut s'empêcher de citer au passage le
bilan publié il y a quelques jours par
le gouvernement fédéral confirmant que
les émissions de GES du Canada sont
remontés en 2021 par rapport à 2020
toujours pas en train de planifier
sérieusement la sortie des énergies
fossiles à l'échelle des pays du G7 les
sept pays membres du G7 ont en revanche
promis dimanche de réduire à zéro leur
pollution plastique additionnelle d'ici
2040 certes une bonne nouvelle mais une
date trop loinaine croit Patrick
mais faudra le faire beaucoup plus
rapidement par exemple le Canada vise
2030 pour la fin de la pollution
plastique tandis que les événements
climatiques extrêmes se multiplient dans
le monde et que les experts du GIEC
sonnent continuellement l'alarme Patrick
bonnet et André annebrason font tout de
habilers mitigé de ce dernier sommet il
y a certainement quelques avancées mais
on peut pas dire qu'on sent un réel
changement de paradigme de la part des
pays du G7 quelques avancées
malheureusement la somme n'est pas la
hauteur de ce que Dewa faire le G7
c'est en novembre prochain à Dubaï que
les dirigeants du monde se réuniront à
nouveau dans le cadre de la cop28 ici
Radio-Canada Montréal